We have some very interesting new polling
from these early days of the Joe Biden administration.
And sixty nine percent of Americans approve
of Joe Biden's week one covid response.
And if you know anything about the hyper partizan
and politicized, divided nature of the United
States, 69 percent of Americans agreeing about
anything is pretty remarkable.
And there are even better numbers than that.
This is an ABC News Ipsos poll released yesterday.
69 percent of Americans support Joe Biden's
covid-19 response.
Thus far, that's 97 percent of Democrats,
70 percent of independents.
But very interestingly, almost half of Republicans,
40 percent of Republicans approve of the way
Joe Biden so far has handled coronavirus.
Now, in comparison, the highest approval rate
that Trump ever had on the pandemic was 55
percent.
But when was it?
It was mid-March.
What did Trump done in mid-March?
I think it was March 12th or 15th that Trump
said were shutting down travel from China
or Europe.
That was his high point of 55 percent.
And it's only been down from there.
Joe Biden already at 69 percent approval on
coronavirus.
What is he done so far that people approve
of?
Well, on day one, he did sign the executive
orders.
He promised to sign the federal facemask mandate
at federal buildings and on transportation,
et cetera.
He also put together a number of other specific
plans which are yet to be voted on in terms
of coronavirus stimulus, vaccine distribution.
And much, much more interestingly, the mask
mandate has 81 percent support across the
country, 81 percent support.
And Joe Biden also importantly stopped the
American withdrawal from the World Health
Organization immediately putting Dr. Anthony
Fauci is the sort of liaison or spokesperson
for the U.S. in the rekindled relationship
with the WHL. 70 percent of Americans also
agree with getting back into or halting our
exit from the W.H.
Oh, this is a really, really big deal.
And the reason it's a big deal is that, again,
in this country, it's really hard to get numbers
that high on anything.
If you you know, we've talked before on presidential
approval, you have probably 20 percent of
the country who will never abandon the president
and 20 percent of the country that will never
approve of the job the president's doing.
Meaning, even though on paper a president's
approval could be between zero and 100.
It's really probably between 20 and 80.
And when we look at the data over recent times
about do you think Trump really won the election,
the people who thought even up until January
20th and maybe still today, that somehow Trump
is going to get a second term, 30 percent
of this country seems basically cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs.
And I know some people won't like that phrase,
but what I mean is there is a non-trivial
portion of this country, 25, 30 percent, maybe
that includes that 20 that will never abandon
Trump, plus another five to 10 percent that
thinks they are evaluating the situation and
coming to those same conclusions that is completely
disconnected from reality, completely disconnected
from from empiricism and facts and thinking
and rationality.
And so when you see, wow, in a country where
25 or 30 percent of the country is whacked,
81 percent approval on a mask mandate, that
really tells you something.
These are numbers that are in practice effectively
as close to unanimity as you can expect to
get in a country that says ideologically,
call it diverse as the United States.
We also have from this new poll, this ABC
News Ipsos poll, the question of do you believe
Joe Biden will unite the country?
Now, at the top of the show, I said no.
What I regardless of Joe Biden's efforts,
I don't believe that we will see a United
United States in any true sense.
57 percent of respondents believe that Joe
Biden will make progress in uniting the country.
Not a great number.
But it's something and we will continue to
track all of this data.
We are starting to see cases now, as I predicted
months ago, this isn't because of anything
Joe Biden did.
Yet we are starting to see cases come down
from their pandemic high around January 10th
and hopefully they will continue on down.
Hopefully, deaths will turn the corner.
Hospitalizations in many areas are already
going down.
So let's hope that we continue in this direction
under Joe Biden.